Hello, welcome!
In this AI Coffee Break, we are going to see
how a language model, usually applied on natural
language, can solve biology problems!
Is this not at least a little bit crazy?
So far in the Transformer series, we have
seen how we can use Transformer-based language
models like BERT or GPT-2, GPT-3 on text.
Or on images, or even on both!
But what if Ms. Coffee Bean tells you, we
can use Transformers for analysing protein
structure!
So in this video, we will explain what the
biological problem is and why we can solve
it with a transformer model originally meant
for natural language!
This method we are talking about, was published
quite recently. Oh, come on, who are we kidding,
it was published one month ago!
One month ago in Machine Learning, is way
old!
Anyway, let’s get back to the subject: What
does this paper do? It takes BERT, a Transformer
model, like we presented it in a previous
video, linked below.
We remember, BERT is trained on masked word
prediction and one of the most important internal
mechanisms is self-attention.
Self-attention computes importance scores
between tokens (words or subwords) in the
same sequence.
Attention computes importance scores between
tokens from different sequences.
And we do not compute one attention per sequence,
but multiple attention scores, called attention
heads, here color-coded.
By learning to predict words in natural language,
the model learns more complex relationships,
present in language, like for example parts
of speech co-reference, sentiment and so on.
Because Bert is notorious for learning implicit
patterns in the data, for discovering structure
that is not even annotated, a whole sub-field
emerged, called BERTology: What does the BERT
model learn about natural language?
A method of finding out if BERT learned something
about another task B, while being trained
on task A, is called probing. We discussed
it in a previous video, linked in the description
below.
Until now, we have explained the BERTology
part of the title. Where is the biology?
Ah, here it is!
In the central dogma of biology, there are
three important pieces that play a role in
how cells live and reproduce: the DNA, the
RNA and the proteins. For the sake of this
video, we can simplify this by saying DNA
is the blueprint of the cell, whereas proteins
are the machinery built from this blueprint.
The DNA contains a sequence of bases often
encoded as the letters ATG and C. This sequence
is then transcribed into RNA and then translated
further into the language of amino acids.
Amino acids are just molecules , but when
connected into a long string, they form proteins.
Similarly, to how we encode bases as the letters
A T G and C, we can also encode the 20 amino-acids
with letters from the alphabet. This amino-acid
sequence is important for a well-functioning
protein. But some amino acids have very similar
chemical properties and could be exchanged
without breaking the viability of the protein.
Until now, we regarded proteins as a 2D sequence
of amino-acids. Only that proteins exist in
3D space, how else?
So important for the function of the protein,
is not only the amino-acid sequence, but also
the three-dimensional shape that this long
line of molecules takes. Biologists call this
the secondary and tertiary structure.
The tertiary structure is the overall shape
of the protein, the secondary structure describes
recurring sub-shapes such as turns and folds,
helices, and sheets.
Because proteins are folded into themselves
in complicated 3D shapes, some amino acids
are very close to each other in 3D space,
even though they are far away from each other
in the 2D sequence.
And proteins don’t all work by themselves,
but sometimes they interact with
each other and bind at well defined binding
sites.
Equipped with this biological knowledge, let’s
look at how BERT could help in protein biology.
In natural language, we have text, which is
a sequence of words. These words could form
simple or more complicated meanings and patterns,
for example a simple pattern would be to identify
that different words have a different part
of speech.
One is a verb, the other one a noun and these
patterns are not explicitly marked or annotated,
but they contribute heavily to conveying meaning.
More complex patterns would be co-reference
or sentiment, and so on.
On the other side, we have protein sequences,
where the “words” are the amino acids.
Similarly, they also have intrinsic structural
properties like the secondary structure, the
tertiary structure or the binding sites.
So let us see, if BERT that works on language
and identifies the inner structure of language
with the attention mechanism so well, can
also work on these sequences of amino acids
and tell us more about the inner biological
workings of the cell!
The idea then would be to train BERT like
we train usually on language, by masked language
modelling: We take the amino acid sequence,
mask a portion of them and let BERT train
while predicting what the masked amino-acid
might be!
And this task would be for BERT quite simple:
While English has a vocabulary of around 10,000
words, we have only about 20 amino-acids to
consider, should be easy, right?
Well, it's not that easy, because we want
to also learn something about interesting
biology here. Reconstructing missing amino
acids in the sequence is not our main goal.
So for detecting interesting properties, like
secondary and tertiary structures or binding
sites, the authors are analyzing the attention
patterns.
They do this by measuring the correlation
of the attention of each head to different
properties of the amino acid.
Like in natural language, some attention heads
in BERT focus on only one specific word, for
example “the” or “I” in a sentence.
Here, for proteins, we have a head focusing
on the occurrence of only one amino-acid,
for example proline.
More interesting properties can be interpreted
from this result. Attention heads that focus
on one amino-acid, also have a high attention
score for amino-acids with which they can
be substituted with.
So amino acids with similar chemical properties
share high attentions! This is similar to
what we observe with synonyms in natural language!
We can also find attention heads that align
with the contact maps, meaning that in the
three dimensional structure, these amino acids
are close to each other.
The authors saw that this head’s attention
is a very well calibrated estimator for the
probability of contact.
For binding sites this attention gets more
complicated, since binding sites are more
difficult to describe biologically, because
there are many different types of binding
sites. This is why, there are more heads working
together on describing this phenomenon.
This paper is a nice proof of concept that
many sequence-based data types can be processed
by the Transformer architecture. Without any
explicit annotation, the model figures out
interesting phenomena by itself!
If you liked this video, please tell everybody
about Ms. Coffee Bean, and do not forget to
hit the subscribe and like buttons! Bye!